hey everyone bennett here you know a
couple months ago i did a video called
breath of the wild 2's story where i
tried to come up with breath of the wild
2's story using a i story generators you
know artificial intelligence you know
robots before they try to use us that is
because it's gonna happen guys
the robots are gonna take over
we can't run
we can't hide
so anyway i decided to do another one
because since i've done that video
several things have changed one my
hair's gotten longer two nintendo
dropped a second trailer for the sequel
to breath of the wild a sequel to the
trailer for the sequel if you will so
since we're all about sequels here may
as well do a sequel to our ai video
because sequels are always supposed to
be better than the original in that
right nintendo
right nintendo sequels are better
nintendo you better freaking take out
that weapon durability system or i swear
i swear anyway because this sequel to
the ai video is going to be better than
the first one i figured we'll use the
same ai story generators that we did the
first time but we're going to add a few
more just to make it i don't know better
hopefully i don't know i haven't done
this i'm not even scripting this we're
just gonna fly by the seat of our pants
so to say and see what happens i don't
know if that's a weird thing to say
i heard it growing up or something i
don't know somebody validate me in the
comments anyway here we go okay so here
we are on a google page where i am just
looking for new ai story generators i
know that some of you in the last video
had told me about some
uh really high quality ai story
generators but i looked for your
comments i could not find them for the
life of me so anyway i just came up with
as you can see in my very transparent
tabs here i have five of them selected
one of them is named jarvis so we'll see
how that goes anyway we're gonna start
with this one from the first video and
we're just kind of going to redo all the
blanks here with stuff from the new
trailer now there is quite a bit to fill
out here and i'm going to uh probably
just do it all and record it and then
just speed it up so that you guys don't
have to sit through all of it so anyway
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
okay and finally what is your pen name
my pen name is as always mr bandit write
me a short story all right guys here we
go
so this it's already great okay all
right i zoomed in a little bit
i'm going to read this to you as
seriously as i can i hope you are as
serious as i am
here we go
from mr bandit the hard sword that's
gonna be the name of breath of the wild
sequel the legend of zelda the hard
sword a short story by mr bandit link
link looked at the hard sword in his
hands and felt brave he walked over to
the window and reflected on his pretty
surroundings he had always loved up
skyrim with its famous funny floating
islands it was a place that encouraged
his tendency to feel brave then he saw
something in the distance or rather
someone it was the figure of ganon dwarf
ganon was a tall corpse with ginger arms
and large hair
[Music]
link gulped he glanced at his own
reflection he was a brave courageous
noble pursuit drinker with blonde arms
and short hair why do they keep doing
that his friends saw him as a
kaleidoscopic keen knight
once he had even revived a dying
princess
but not even a brave person who had once
revived a dying princess was prepared
for what ganon had in store today
the cloudy teased like diving birds
making link angry as link stepped
outside and ganon came closer he could
see the defeated smile on his face ganon
glared with all the wrath of
6460 powerful clear cow he said in
hushed tones i hate you and i want his
life link looked back even more angry
and still fingering the hard sword ganon
we meet again boy he replied what no
that was supposed okay they looked at
each other with happy feelings like two
deadly damaged dogs jumping at a very
short skydiving which had piano music
playing in the background and two blue
uncles killing into the beat
suddenly ganon lunged forward and tried
to punch link in the face quickly link
grabbed the hard sword and brought it
down on ganon's skull ganon's ginger
arms trembled and his large hair wobbled
he looked scared his emotions wrong like
a hilarious homely hand then he let out
an agonizing groan and collapsed onto
the ground moments later ganondorf was
dead
link link went back inside and made
himself a nice drink of the noble
pursuit the end
well that was beautiful and it was a
little bit similar to the two stories
that we did in the first video but
that's just because we used the same uh
short story generator here but uh that
was the hard sword let me know what you
thought in the comments below about um
you know gannon with his tall corpse and
ginger arms and large hair moving on to
the next one this one's called writer uh
looks like uh let's see all i do is tell
a writer what i need and it writes
everything for me some creepy ai stuff
going on there okay so i'm just gonna
continue with my mask nintendo bandit
account oh i don't need no tutorial get
out of here okay so it's gonna be in
english it's gonna be
convincing critical critical obviously a
story where is it story plot here we go
a story plot a time when i couldn't
distinguish ai from humans oh
after link
dove through the sky he fought gendorf
to save zelda oh we can do two variants
let's do two variants okay so all i do
is just write this little story idea
here and then say write for me and you
know what i'll do three variants right
for me
okay so it it went ahead and and oh my
god lincoln zelda had been captured and
ganondorf was out to steal the triforce
of wisdom zelda reveals that she is not
the real zelda but her alter ego
ganondorf gets the triforce of wisdom
and with it creates a portal in the sky
with dark clouds and lightning bolts
link and zelda escape and fight their
way through forces of darkness to reach
ganondorf only to be faced with an
invisible invincible force link throws
himself into the portal saving zelda in
the process link was in a coma for three
days after he saved at least it wasn't
100 years right for three days after he
saved zelda which let ganondorf use his
evil magic to change times so that he
had already obtained all three pieces of
the triforce yo this is so good link
awakes in an unfamiliar building in
hyrule field
field
which is now devoid of any life
the castle is overrun with ganondorf's
evil forces and no one can enter or
leave town because of a wall that has
been created that prevents anyone from
getting past it without
is that the end of the story so let's
end it by saying without dot dot dot
that's some good stuff there there's
very little to do with sky rule the
second story just says unsafe
i'm just gonna trust the ai at that the
third story is link was at the edge of
the world but he could see nothing but
ocean as he looked over the edge a
strong wind pushed him off oh no he
thought as he fell that this is it he
saw a small island in the distance and
as he got closer it became clearer that
it was hyrule this high reception you
guys fall off of hyrule to enter hyrule
link landed on a small peak that
overlooked hyrule and could see
ganondorf with zelda in his arms
ganondorf laughed and said to link
you will never save her link jumped
towards ganondorf and fought him with
his sword his hard sword ganondorf
dodged every attack and laughed as if to
prove a point about defeating link link
retreated back to the peak waiting for
ganondorf to come after him again to
prove his point about how powerless link
is against him as ganondorf came close
link leaped up and threw the horizon
just as zelda's voice said into his head
help me
link saw all of hyrule oh you know what
from the
floating islands of skyrim dot dot dot
right is is pretty cool not gonna lie it
has some way of scouring the web and
figuring out what key words can go with
the keywords that you gave it because
all this stuff like trivorce of wisdom
hyrule field even i didn't say that in
my story idea this is a pretty good one
you know i'll write this one a
seven coke zeros out of eight diet cokes
okay moving on to jarvis i was very oh
look i can use 10 000 words to try
jarvis for free oh okay it's like a
trial uh no i just wanted to do the free
trial you guys i just wanted to do the
free trial all right y'all it appears to
me that i'm not gonna be able to do the
free trial unless i actually start off
and sign up for a subscription
very sad i wanted to try out jarvis but
oh well bye bye jarvis okay on to the
third one
full screen this boy okay type some text
here in a neural network will generate
more press tab at any point to generate
more text and escape to stop or revert
let's just start typing text
after the castle
battle
link took to sky rule
he
dove
among
no no no that sounds really stupid that
sounds really stupid you guys just stop
me when i start sounding stupid okay
just
yeah you just yell yeah i'll hear you i
you're yelling okay that's a little loud
stop yelling
no you can keep yelling you do what you
want oh
i can't type okay uh generate text whoa
okay okay wait wait
i'm not i'm not looking i'm gonna let it
go okay the thought of meeting a
familiar face however was almost
unbearable to him at the moment link
could not help but freeze in his tracks
due to the horrifying appearance of the
beast of the joker
upon seeing him zelda still trapped
within her sleep trance noticed that
link was completely frozen in his tracks
and just staring at the joker zelda then
placed her hands on link's cheeks and
wait you know what i think i can just
keep going with this right yes i can
said to him in hushed tones
link
you are the light the light of hyrule
that must shine
wait i got it wrong but you get where
i'm going but that must shine once again
but suddenly
ganondorf
and okay keep keep keep generating oh
man if there's a new monster called the
joker i think i'm gonna flip but
suddenly ganondorf appeared and started
to ask the joker his questions he asked
the question where is zelda in a loud
hoarse voice the joker simply replied to
ganondorf with a simple simply replied
with a symbol i don't know what you're
talking about but
joker being the joker link then had an
idea and the light seemed to suddenly
turn off and he finally regained his
composure and ran off
while running he was able to break the
joker's hand before he could answer
ganondorf truthfully okay guys this is
the last little segment that we're gonna
do and then we're gonna end it with this
ai
let's see what's a good way to wrap it
up before we can answer ganondorf
truthfully no matter what this new
adventure might bring
link was determined to use his new found
powers
to defeat
ganondorf
not only once again but once and for all
also joker died and didn't show
up again in the story okay generate that
but
but thanks to dr weak who's blood and a
figure known as the shining leader some
people think that the joker might have
been killed as he came back
is the ai arguing with me now did i just
try to kill joker off and they i was
like no i'm a joker and i liked that
character so he came back oh my god i'm
actually kind of scared right now where
did he go the shining leader mentioned
the possibility that the joker survived
his fall from the loft
while others think that the
jack-o-lantern and the joker are one of
the same which do you believe also there
is talk at the west end
okay well this ai generator is very very
interesting like where did the joker
come from or dr weiku or the shining
leader i don't know i thought it was
really interesting when it started uh
arguing with me right here a little
scary anyway um that is all for this
video i hope you enjoyed it let me know
if you want to see other weird ai story
generated stuff like this in the future
for maybe some other franchises and uh
leave a like on this video if you
enjoyed it of course oh and also
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
for much more nintendo content to come
um i would have liked for there to have
been a nintendo direct this month
but i guess that's just not going to
happen unless it is nintendo
anyway like i've said several times now
that's about it this is mass nintendo
bandit looking forward to seeing you in
the next one and signing out
[Music]
you